thank you all very very much this
concludes thank you
everybody thank you everyone this
concludes the all right that was
President Joe Biden at the White House
with President Vladimir zalinsky of
Ukraine where funding for Ukraine is
stuck the president refuses to fund
proper border security so we're at an
impass over the $60 billion that's been
requested to fund that war a war which
is now in a stalemate there's trench
warfare the lines have dug in in the
count are offensive by the
ukrainians is stuck so right now he's
asking for more money Congress is not
giving it to him and he has just
promised eventual NATO membership to
Ukraine which seems uh quite provocative
considering that Russian troops are in
that territory and both President Joe
Biden and zalinski says that total
Victory is the strategy so it looks like
we're not headed towards peace
negotiations at all judge Janine do you
think the president was persu u asive in
selling the American people in Congress
that we need to fund this war in
perpetuity well I I don't think that any
American wants to fund any war in
perpetuity if they don't believe that it
affects them and you know I don't know
that he made the case that it affects
Americans which is the look The
Americans are in favor of democracy and
and making sure that Putin doesn't
invade and all that but you know the
idea that he says we will not walk away
from Ukraine we need to win we're not
ready to sit down and engage in peace
talks I mean which is kind of you know
inconsistent with the way he's talking
about Israel with Israel he said you
know you have to be careful he's warning
of changing public opinion and the
assault in Israel was on October 7th
this is this is December 10th 11th
whatever it is and yet this war has been
going on they started building up the
troops in the spring of uh I believe it
was 2021 and then we started in 2022
Biden doesn't want to go into a campaign
uh for president in the middle of a war
and I don't know that the Americans have
the the the the hunger to make sure we
stay in it till they win and you know we
got to make sure that Ukraine gets into
NATO no I don't think America sold on
that but what's interesting he says the
one or two lines that he talked about
our border the American Border he says
and I'm looking for a bipartisan
compromise to solve the Border crisis
you know as opposed to we're going to
close the border and we're going to
prosecute people who violate the law
coming in so I think he's all over the
place uh and I think that in the end he
just wants to keep giving money to
Ukraine the Americans are skeptical as
well they should be it's in very easy
deal to make Dana if he wants to make it
he just has to fund border security and
then Republicans will fund the Ukraine
war it's it seems like there's agreement
on that well what happened is that doing
the aid package for Israel and Ukraine
was already a difficult thing to do
getting the Border policy money is also
a difficult thing to do the Biden
Administration and their wisdom and
their strategy was to combine them as if
that would make it easier for it to pass
rather than making it much much harder
because they make another fundamental
miscalculation they thought if they said
hey Republicans we're going to ask for
more border money cool and the
Republicans said well well we'll talk
about it but actually we are looking for
some policy changes we want more money
and the Republicans have all of them
locked arms and said Red Rover Red Rover
send it on over and and the the
Democrats as far as I've heard in the
negotiations are not even willing to do
basic horse trading it was the Biden
Administration who opened this door to
get border money in exchange for the aid
for Israel and Ukraine so they have to
come to the table because the Biden
Administration might have mayorcas go
out and say oh the border is closed no
problem but the American people people
are watching on their screens every day
especially if you're watching Fox and
perhaps only if you're watching Fox the
numbers of people streaming into this
country if you live in New York Chicago
Denver San Francisco LA you're hearing
about all the migrants that are coming
and putting your city into a death
spiral so they added a hard thing to
another hard thing and they're surprised
that it's hard one point on the NATO
membership thing that's been US policy
for a long long time what would have
been huge news is if Biden had said
Ukraine NATO membership is off the table
because if he had said that that would
have been an immediate death blow to
zalinski and he might as well not even
go home Jessica what's the problem with
the Republican border ask they just want
to change the Asylum laws that have been
abused for the last three
years so I think that John fedman who
and I'm glad that rep uh Republicans are
now seeing the worth of the man and he
has recovered from his stroke and guess
what he loves Israel and he thinks it's
okay to talk about a enforced border is
where the Democratic party is going to
end up on this to say it is not
xenophobic it is not bigoted to talk
about what's going on the border that
doesn't mean that you give the other
side exactly what they want it's not
just money to reform the Asylum system
there are people who don't believe in
building a wall in that way who feel
that whatever the system turns into it
will be too cruel that it will be uh too
Limited in terms of who can get in here
but I think crel if yes that there are
people who have or or the migrants to
the migrants who are legitimately seing
Asylum we are a country of immigrants
and we're talking about reforming a
legal system I'm not talking about
pouring it I wanted to add though it was
newly minted speaker Mike Johnson who
talked about attaching the Ukrainian Aid
and the Israeli Aid to each other and
then he also wanted to take cuts to the
IRS in order to get money for that so
this isn't all about the Democrats just
smooshing everything together Johnson
knew that he has a large contingent of
Republicans in his caucus who are not
into supporting Ukraine anymore and so
he was trying to bring it around that it
would support Israel as well and then
threw in this clunker with the IRS thing
um yes on Dana's NATO point it's
obviously where zalinsky wants to go the
odds of them ever getting there in terms
of membership I think are incredibly
limited um they're not going to meet
those um
criteria but I didn't think that Biden
wavered on the Israel issue again he was
Defensive of Israel's ability to flood
the tunnels where we know terrorists
hang out and made it clear that they've
said they don't think hostages are there
we don't know for sure which is why you
have to be cautious with it but his
position hasn't changed and they voted
against the ceasefire today at the UN
again one of 10 countries that did it um
they've been very strong on the Israel
issue all right Greg I say let's go
another two years it's not our blood
it's not our blood it's not our boys
dying out there who cares right and you
know what it's going to be a white
Christmas for those defense contractors
right that was the good news I got out
of this this war is putting billions
into our country now if I were person I
think America is a business and the
business is War I think it's really
depressing uh a lot of people pointed
out this is where this was headed a
stalemate a NeverEnding stalemate and it
will continue as long as they keep
telling you there's progress oh there's
progress that was about as persuasive as
a sandpaper jock strap that
President it's just embarrassing and and
to to have the gall to like insult
people who put America first you know if
you want to have a their border the
Ukraine border matters more than our
border we have thousands of people dying
from drugs coming across the border
we've got gangs uh from Chile coming in
but that's not important what's
important is their border a fight
between relative countries that we
shouldn't even be there we shouldn't
even be there it that it's too late to
say this war was totally prev Venable we
knew the red lines but we wanted to get
Putin out and now if you question it at
all you're qu you're almost being
unpatriotic about Ukraine yeah you know
you're in Putin's pocket if you point
out the obvious you cannot believe any
side on this I'm sorry you can say one
day and it's true everybody at home
knows this one day you hear Russians
Russians Russia's losing the next day
Ukraine's Ukraine's winning uh and then
Ukraine's losing it goes back and forth
and it's as long as it goes back and
forth it just keeps going and keep going
we've had enough we've had enough Biden
says history will judge us harshly he
will judge you
harshly okay more on the five coming up
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else